l'aps est parti pour un nouveau vote
enveloppes salue la team menthe à l'eau
aujourd'hui j'ai deux sièges avec moi ce
qui veut dire que je peux recevoir une
personne mais deux personnes est la
première personne c'est serrage
oh mon dieu il apparaît comme ça c'est
incroyable il ya un travail de post prod
mon pote céréales de la chaîne des
cibles salut non choisie c'est pas faire
des soins il a eu le courage de dire oui
à tout pendant 30 jours
je dis pas de bêtises je m'arrête sinon
durant 30 jours fériés ce mal en fait
pour ceux qui veulent voir à peu près à
quoi ça ressemble le la parodie quitte
là dessus c'est yes man justement avec
jim carrey le film exactement regard
d'état qui se transforme en jim carrey
exactement ça voilà et c'est j'aimerais
mentir c'était - bah oui c'est un sketch
était inspiré du film ben j'avais vu le
film n'est en danger mais je n'ai pas
revu pour l'occasion mais moi ça et est
ce qu ont validé le serait bienvenu chez
aux troupes d'accord yes entre le film
l'idée que ça te provoque et le fait de
le faire tu t'es renseigner un peu s'il
y en a qui l'avait fait ou non pas son
passé un projet la vision des produits
sont vachement réfléchi ouais et là en
fait c'était une blague à la base ce qui
donne baleti ça qui m'a dit pourquoi je
disais oui à tout parce qu'il ya une
troisième personne qui s'appelle
laetitia elle s'y attend une transfuge
du conseil comprend cette phrase et
faisons là apparaître à accueillons tous
types laëtitia mais je me lance dans la
magie sa laeticia de la chaîne le corps
la maison l'esprit pourquoi je fais
apparaître et issia parce que durant ce
défi des 30 jours où tu as dit oui à
tout laëtitia était pas un seul ace
reprendre ton explication du convient de
noter là bas au début c'était une blague
que chose un litige qui étaient très
drôles ou friends et tu dis oui à tout
et moi je disais que c'était un défi
parce que souvent on met les gens se
moquent de moi en bien fait ce défilé en
raison des défis bête
moi je me reprends j'ai dit ouais c'est
un défi de dire oui à tout et en fait
c'est une blague que les gens ont
vraiment cru tous les gens qui méritent
vraiment cru et s'adjuge une semaine tu
vas aller au bout d'une semaine de
blague j'ai dû commencer à dire mon fait
c'était pas vrai mais je vais quand même
le faire sérieusement pendant 30 jours
donc j'ai vraiment trois questions à
poser la première ces quantités lancé ce
défi là est ce qu'il y avait un objectif
autre que d'essayer de le faire et voir
ce que tu en retirer
j'ai pas vraiment réfléchi sur place
c'est vrai c'est un peu toujours une
blague quoi jusqu'au bout et surtout je
m'attendais vraiment à voir des trucs
très négatif on va être comme dans le
film fait dans le finalement il ya un
sdf qui tu prends tout son argent qui
veulent sa voiture et tous et moi
j'attendais de voir en fait
voici allait avoir des trucs très
négatif ou des trucs positifs
finalement il y arrive et même très
négatif quoi mais dans ma tête c'était
juste voie y avait pas d'objectif
c'était juste de changer un peu la
routine et de faire des trucs nouveaux
inversement des gens qui savent et tu
étais en train de faire le défi est ce
qu'ils ont essayé d'en profiter et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ben il ya eu
plus des gens déjà franchement les gens
qui savent pas dans l'ensemble guitario
landgraf contient 18 oui si tu dis à
personne que tu dis ouais tout
franchement il se passe pas grand chose
de grave que le seul truc c'est tu
donnes de l'argent à tout le monde et tu
achètes m'importe est pourquoi je suis
pas venu chez turn10 souhaite par
exemple on met le truc c'est que tu as
les gens qui du coup qu'ils ne
connaissent pas donc lui savent pas
forcément que je ferais plus via
semaines donc il me demande rien de fou
et à des gens qui te connaissent d'à
priori c'est plutôt tes amis et et eux
ils disent plutôt des trucs sympas en
fait moi j'ai pas mal d'amis qui m'ont
demandé de l'argent à des genres des
grosses sommes et à chaque fois je leur
donnais 200 300 euros mais en fait à
chaque fois nous le rende et tôt ou tard
à oui d'accord c'est normal on faire
quand tu réfléchis de seconde ben ouais
mais c'est intéressant parce que pour le
coup quand j'ai su que tu faisais le
défi ou comme tout le monde
premier truc que j'ai fait c'était
demandé un truc vraiment à la con
attendu avec moi je sais plus mais
georges que j'ai dû dire avant de
financement nouveau spectacle par
exemple tu vois c'est un crédit pour moi
où j'ai dû sortir une bonne comme ça et
tu m'as fait oui et bien sentiment qui
est belle non en fait après tu avec
facile mais maintenant je vais essayer
de jouer avec lui mais en fait moi j'ai
profité de jouer
parce que je lui ai demandé de le
continuer donc il continue pour moi et
donc il a l'obligation de me dire oui à
tout encore aujourd'hui encore
maintenant à temps et si c'est à peu
près ça mais le jeu serait que je lui ai
fait faire c'est de monter avec moi à
bruxelles et de rentrer dans le complot
de bruxelles pour le projet juncker pour
le 3g projet juncker c'est le nom de
code du projet news vous avez pas vu ce
qui s'est passé avec ça et c'est pas
possible que vous n'ayez pas vu laeticia
il ya eu en quelques mots en fête il ya
la commission européenne en partenariat
avec youtube qui recevait trois youtuber
de trois pays pour poser des questions à
juncker le président en vie la
présentation le président de la
commission européenne
et vous vous avez filmé toutes les
coulisses de sa puisqu'il y avait on te
demande est plutôt un certain style de
questions sont imposés de question et
toi tu voulais aborder d'autres sujets
et on te faisait comprendre ne pas les
aborder et au final durant le direct a
posé des questions et je vous laisse
découvrir ça directement sur les chaînes
et les is young s'est surprise et ça
s'est bien passé
oui ça s'est bien passé enfin il ya ça
oui et lui s'est retrouvé dans cette
aventure là grâce à et ce mal est fait
et c'est quand même un gros truc auquel
je suis jamais arrivé se répète il ya un
truc parce que ça au final c'est normal
que je dis oui parce que c'était marrant
mais j'aurais pas été avec toi ce moment
là j'aurais pas été dans la dynamique
oui c'est ça c'est en fait sacrer une
dizaine auraient tout rationaliser en
ayant des chemins de décision à
différents etc
c'est ça qui est intéressant qu'un truc
quoi ça te fait pas mal voyagé aussi
j'en mangeais la paranoïa qui m'a
proposé qui m'a donné ces clés pour
barcelone un appart à barcelone il m'a
dit vas-y vas-y maintenant si tu veux et
en fait c'est le moment où je me suis
rabattu en fait c'est super son projet
je continue à dire oui et je veux
vraiment le faire sérieusement quand je
me suis [ __ ] ça donne que des bonnes
opportunités et est donc passé le
premier voyage que j'ai fait avec
l'accord et après bruxelles
c'est pareil comme un c si j'avais fait
un plan précis pour arriver à ce point
là en fait j'aurais même pas pensé à j'y
serai paraît alors quand l'idée du yes
man c'est aussi de permettre au hasard
de d'amener des situations encore plus
beauf que je suis forcément pu vivre
autrement passé ce qui s'est passé ça
fait un escalier comme ça et est un des
zones importe quelle démarche qui met un
nom quelque part et
serait-ce la gueule quoi et est ce que
tu as une limites déontologiques quand
même à tonga bamanans donc là j'ai
vraiment rien pour moi battez j'aurais
dû le faire mais en fait je me suis
vraiment dit voulais faire à fond et
voilà ne pas avoir de limites du tout en
tout cas je pense qu'ils sont
bienveillants et je pense pour l'avoir
ressentie avec toi que au delà de la
bienveillance après il ya les espèces de
barrières personnels qui font que tu
manière t'as pas envie faire de mal à
l'autre
c'est quand est ce que tu vas abusé mais
c'est je crois que c'est très gênant
pour l'autre de se dire attends il se
met en position d'esclaves
volontairement si elle décide qu'il est
mon esclave est ce que j'ai envie d'être
ce mec là en fait tu vois pas ce qu'on
parle toujours de là j'ai gagné j'ai
manipulé j'avais fait ça mais quand eux
quand de le libre accès en fait ça
devient presque gênant fait fait d'un
gta final c'est encore mieux peut-être
on me demande mon truc en fait chaud
ouais je sais plus quel genre au début
j'avais envie de me cacher que sur les
épaules et yes man et puis en me
rapprochant de semaine j'en avais un peu
marre qu'ils me laissent l'amérique vers
mon futur je devais être monde en fait
et même quand tu rencontres des gens
comme ça on a eu des situations on était
dans le métro on est avec des gens qu'on
connaissait pas et on leur expliquait et
il demande aux jambes
bah dites moi de faire quelque chose et
les gens ils sont là à ben non en fait
je fais en rien c'est drôle mais je te
dis c'est très bien parce que quand on
obtient quelque chose de quelqu'un
d'autre
en fait on obtient en même temps
l'acceptation de sa part donc on sait
que quoi qu'il arrive il a accepté ça
soit dans un schéma de peur de
rationalisation ou dans vie mais il a
accepté
donc on est libéré comment te dire on
est libéré de
[ __ ] je trouve pas mon mot on est
libéré notre propre responsabilité de la
demande mais comme toi on sait que tu
vas dire oui à tout et qui a tort a pas
de schumann décision on est responsable
de notre demande tu vois et là tu nous
impose la responsabilité et du coup dans
la société actuelle on est souvent
déresponsabiliser on suit des règles
ensuite un code de la route on suit les
lois et comme ça tu vois et ça nous
rassure parce qu'on aime bien être cadré
et toi tu enlèves ce cadre-là et du coup
au wawel tu sais pas comment manipuler
cette relation là où tout ça va faire
réaliser en fait les gens quand ils
demandent un truc ils veulent pas
vraiment à voir ce truc il va lui
l'avoir extrait en vie exactement ce
qu'ils ont à dire cette possibilité
possibilité là en fait c'est un belge
ont pas dû tomber te demander quoi que
tu as vécu le jour où ça s'arrêtait et
il avait du mal à dire non c'est toi que
j'ai dit je pars jamais encore
aujourd'hui ouais parce qu'en fait
c'étaient deux salles c'est ce que tu
avais expliqué c'est que ça te prenais
plus d'énergie en fait
ah oui le truc vraiment certain que tu
réfléchis plus
alors pendant 30 jours il pas réfléchir
vraiment on va tout ce que je faisais la
fin de compte est bon un truc que je me
faisais quoi et ça c'est une poussée des
vacances incroyable quoi c'est vraiment
trop besoin de faire un bail parce que
tu as battu voix sur la
responsabilisation de noms je parlais
tout à l'heure tu aussi ta virer toute
part de responsabilité puisque donnerait
un chemin de fer et ses toits away ou
jean et du coup ce que tu penses que
c'est bien parce que les choses que tu
fais tu les fais à 100% avec en tout ça
c'est un autre défi en préparation on a
réparé les ensembles peuvent les socois
vérité absolue honnêteté radical ça
comme ça est ce que c'est le monde
entend livrer dont concept de
développement personnel le net et
radical a dit desmond dans lie to me
dans les premières saisons il ya un mec
qui était dans délire là en fait de
l'honnêteté du coup est ce que tu vas
faire le oui en face je pense connaître
la réponse mais est ce que tu vas faire
une vraie on était radical ou juste une
honnêteté absolue pour moi la différence
et l'honnêteté absolue si tu me pose une
question je te dis la vérité l'honnêteté
radical c'est que t'as pas forcément
posé une question sur quelque chose et
je vais te dire la vérité là par exemple
si j'en avais marre que vous soyez là
vous m'avez rien demandé et dans ces cas
là plutôt que le juste de le ressentir
je l'exprimé basse et plus soit lionel
tardy
c'est aussi un truc émotionnel fait dire
ce que tu ressens moment tu le ressens
ok c'est plus ça que c'est pas juste un
jeu parce qu'il ya un film aussi de jim
carrey du coup aussi sur la lenteur est
amer c'était vraiment ça parce que là
c'est donc tous les toits que bientôt
après il va faire sa vie en film iron
man 2 on est 30 jours et donc voilà
c'est plus bas et fillon faudra dire la
vérité aux questions voilà de manière
technique mais c'est aussi un truc
émotionnel vraiment dire ce que tu
ressens au monde surtout pour ceux qui
voit pas là un lien entre le mentalisme
le yes man et la l'honnêteté radical je
vous plains le lien le lien il est
direct c'est l'évidence même
et je suis à la fois intéressé est
impressionné par le fait de le faire
parce que là il radicalise complètement
des concepts tels médicalisé avec ta
barbe ça m'a fait peur non mais tu vois
qui est l'imbécile décidé de faire des
trucs extrême pour une moyenne facile à
poil c'est hyper intéressant tu vas
faire ça
de quoi calmer je vous recommande
vraiment si vous avez des trucs à
retenir c'est regarder la vidéo dé
laetitia sur juncker cas dans la
description
regardez la vidéo sur le défi yes-man
sur la chaîne de rajouts mais dans la
description est on là c'était une vidéo
un peu rencontre différente comme on
avait pu faire il ya quelques jours avec
clément bompoil caire un synesthète je
sais pas si vous l'avez vu cette voie là
bas elle est allée cool ben en fait
c'est exactement ce que je voulais
reproduire là de me dire en fait j'ai la
chance grâce à la chaîne de rencontrer
encore plus de gens qu'avant et des gens
qui font des choses très spécifiques et
celle est cool de pouvoir les partager
avec vous si ça ça vous plaît n'hésitez
pas à nous faire savoir en laissant un
petit véritable et yes man pouce en
l'air ça vous change rien dire cette
phrase mais voilà que si ça vous a plu
évidemment je ne force à rien bla bla
bla
n'hésitez pas à poser des questions
aussi sur ce qu'on a raconté dans les
commentaires je me ferai un plaisir de
vous y répondre par rapport au yes man
etc
je sais que rage et les tigres ont passé
par là donc je pars voilà ils ont dit qu
à la pompe
s'ils répondent pas ils n'ont pas de
parole et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
à cette chaîne là avant de partir si ce
n'est pas déjà fait et là j'en vois
encore qui ont regardé déjà plein de
vidéos qui sont pas bonnes et
abonnez-vous aux remparts dire pourquoi
parce que le mental blog c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au
31 décembre donc rendez vous demain à 17
heures ciao